hi my name is david shaffer i'm a
professor of chemical and biomolecular
engineering bioengineering and molecular
install biology at uc berkeley
where i'm also director of the berkeley
stem cell center in addition i'm
co-founder of a company called 4d
molecular therapeutics that i'll be
talking about today
so the focus of the work that i'll be
discussing with you today is our efforts
over the past 20 years to
use a technique called directed
evolution to be able to create new
viruses
for therapeutic gene delivery so the
motivation for this work is that there's
serious unmet medical need within our
society
and depending upon which tissue you look
at you can typically see
two categories of diseases so taking the
nervous system in the upper left-hand
corner as an example
we have conditions that affect large
numbers of patients
where the genetics is not entirely clear
it's likely a combination of both
genetic as well as environmental
influences
such as alzheimer's or parkinson's
disease and we also have more rare
conditions
such as stories rhett syndrome
huntington's disease
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis which i'm
sure you otherwise known as lou gehrig's
disease
and these are conditions where you can
pin the blame on specific genetic
changes specific mutations
within particular genes of the human
genome
so regardless of which category of
condition you're looking at however
there's a number of situations in the
nervous system where people have
developed
treatments that can alleviate symptoms
for these horrible conditions
but there are no currently no cures that
are available so for all of these
conditions on this slide
it's quite clear that we need new new
treatments new therapies
so if we take a step back and consider
the basic biology that underlies all
biological function
uh we can see that of course uh dna
encodes
all the genetic information uh on the
planet and uh this information can then
be transcribed
within organisms into rna and then that
in turn becomes translated into a
protein and this
flow of information from dna to rna to
protein of course is called the central
dogma of biology
from the point of view of somebody who's
trying to develop a therapy we can view
each one of these levels as a potential
drug target
so the majority of pharmaceuticals that
are currently in use
target at the level of proteins small
molecules float around
typically bind hydrophobic pockets such
as the active site of an
enzyme and inhibit or alter the function
of that enzyme
monoclonal antibodies float around and
bind to protein targets floating on the
outside of the cell
such as a growth factor or receptor
if we move back one level you can begin
to develop therapies that work at
the level of rna inside of the cell so
these include rna interference or
anti-sense rnas whose goals are to
knock down the production of proteins
from rna or
messenger rna itself can actually be a
therapeutic molecule
but moving one back one further level at
the level of dna
this has really been the focus of my
entire career
so gene therapies the delivery of new
genetic information to a cell genome
editing the
changing or the editing of existing
genetic information inside of a cell
or cell therapies or stem cell therapies
where the goal is to deliver an entirely
new
so the power of targeting dna to be able
to effect a therapeutic outcome
is that the fact that dna unlike small
molecules or proteins
are actually
a tissue so if a new dna
to a cell or tissue that can potentially
persist for the life of a patient
which raises the possibility of single
administration long-term patient benefit
so just to illustrate this idea we have
here the
um on the x-axis the number of years
that the
individual is affected by a particular
condition so typically post-diagnosis
parkinson's patients
are on the order of another 16 years or
so
so congestive heart failure between
diagnosis ultimately when a patient
passes away
due to chf is on the order of 10 years
age-related
macular degeneration it itself is an
addition
it robs people of their vision but
typically does so
towards the life span so they typically
die of other causes after around 10
years of
diagnosis of amd so if we consider or
compare these to the lifetimes
the pharmacokinetic half-lifes of
therapeutic modalities that are
being developed to be able to treat
these conditions we have a small
molecule with a pharmacokinetic
half-life on the
on the order of hours monoclonal
antibodies last
days to several weeks however dna in the
form of a gene therapy
um can potentially last years or even
decades
so here are a couple of examples of gene
therapies one of which i'll be
discussing in more detail
where a single administration back in
the 2000s
led to uh in some cases over a decade of
therapeutic benefit from the patients
who were still enjoying the fact that
they received this gene therapy
many years ago so let's all get on the
same page and actually define what gene
therapy is
it's the delivery of genetic material to
the cells of an individual patient for
therapeutic benefit
and so while this idea was originally
proposed back in the 1960s
we've had to wait for 50 years in order
for it to begin to come to fruition
and the reason is this word highlighted
in yellow here delivery
which is the fact that dna from the
point of view of a cell or an
organ is a very large molecule it's
difficult to get it past the cell
membrane and into the nucleus of a cell
and in addition on its own floating
around in the bloodstream dna is not
particularly stable
it's degraded by nucleases that are
present
so it's been hard to be able to develop
delivery vehicles or vectors that can
carry dna inside of enough cells within
it to begin to move the meat the needle
on treating a disease
so the way that this has been achieved
increasingly over the past
couple of decades is that people have
been identifying viruses very effective
viruses
that can carry dna inside of cells so
aav or adeno-associated virus is a
particularly interesting one
it is risen to be the most promising
virus within the field of gene therapy
for a couple of reasons
first and foremost which of course is a
major factor to discuss today
it's safe it's not a pathogen and in
fact
the majority on the order of 80 to 90
percent of the human population
it's already been infected with this
virus and never even notice it because
it's not associated
with human disease it's a harmless
non-symptomatic virus
in addition it's among the smallest of
viruses so if you take a look at its
genome structure here
it has two genes called repencap and the
rep encode some enzymes that mediate
mediate the replication of the viral dna
the cap has really been the focus of
about half of my career
because the cap encodes some
non-structural pro sorry some structural
proteins
around 60 copies of which self-assembled
to form this particle here on the
right-hand side
and the particle as you can see on the
top side of it there's a black circle
it contains a pore at what you call the
five-fold axis of symmetry
and once this particle is assembled one
copy of the viral dna will snake its way
inside of that pore
to be able to load the virus with its
own genome
only around 4.7 kb in size and the
particle is around 26 nanometers in
dimension
uh importantly a number of natural
variants um well over a hundred
have been identified contain a lot of
sequence variations in the amino acid
compositions on the surface of the virus
so those white peaks for example that
you see emanating from the core of that
viral particle
and these changes in the surface
composition of the virus have been
correlated with changes in
the delivery of the pathway and the
biodistribution and the cell preferences
of the virus
which raises the possibility that by
engineering the surface of the virus
you can actually create highly efficient
targeted viruses
to carry dna medicines to particular
locations inside of a cell
so the way that the virus works is that
after being a
tissue for example the bloodstream or
the lung it makes its way past a number
of barriers
such as bodily fluids it finds its way
to the surface of a target cell
binds to a receptor on that tar on that
target cell surface
undergoes internalization in a
receptor-mediated fashion escapes from
the endosomal network it actually
contains a
domain of the viral protein that enables
its its way to sneak
enables it to sneak its way past that
lipid bilayer that surrounds it
and then uh eventually finds its way
into the nucleus uncoats the viral
capsid and releases the viral dna which
can then go on to to carry out
subsequent steps in the viral life cycle
and the way you turn this into a
therapeutic is you quite simply take the
rep and cap genes
delete them from the viral genome place
them onto a piece of dna
and this results in two outcomes that
are advantageous
one is that it liberates space for the
insertion of a gene of interest
between those flanking sequences those
itrs
and as a result when that viral particle
on the right hand side is assembled
that gene of interest becomes uh
internalized into the viral particle and
your virus then with a a piece of
medicinal or therapeutic dna to treat a
disease
in addition as a result of the fact that
the rep and the cap no longer make it
inside of the virus
this is no longer a replication
competent virus it simply deposits the
gene of interest into the nucleus of a
target cell
and that dna can then persist for long
periods of time
and be able to produce a therapeutic
product such as an rna molecule or a
protein molecule to treat a disease
so this resulting recombinant virus has
a number of advantageous properties it's
very safe like i mentioned 90
of the human population has already been
exposed to one or more natural variants
of aav
it's uh somewhat efficient the natural
variants are
and have been used in over 200 human
clinical trials involving delivery to
muscle liver lung brain and retina
the product of that genome after
delivery is very stable
and persist at least in a non-dividing
cells for years or
a decade and counting and it's possible
to manufacture these at high yields
and as a result of all these properties
the virus is enjoying success with an
increasing number of human clinical
trials resulting for example
uh back in 2017 in the first fda
approval
of a gene therapy for rare disease and
this therapy was based upon an aav
virus and it was to treat a blinding
condition called libra's congenital
amaurosis type 2.
so this is currently being developed and
commercialized and sold by roche
therapeutics
from switzerland uh so we've had seen an
increasing number of successes within
clinical trials
that lca disease um that there was an
fda approval for in 2017
there was an approval for spinal
muscular atrophy
from the artist to be able to treat a
rare
condition which results in fatality and
progressive paralysis and fatality of
young boys
hemophilia b has been has advanced to a
pivotal trial a
phase three clinical trial and shown
strong promise uh hemophilia a is not
that much further behind and uh we have
a long list of successes and
well not that long yet but increasingly
long list of successes that have
resulted from the gene therapy field
however these successes have resulted
some pretty savvy
clinicians who have identified diseases
where the
proper predisposed good good intake
efficacy
but even so these viruses were not
designed
as pharmaceutical gene delivery uh
vehicles
and as a result you've these
investigators have had to really brute
force the delivery
they had to use very very high dosages
of virus or have had to use invasive
routes of administration to place the
virus right next to the target cell
and the field knows that to be able to
build upon these initial successes and
extend them to the majority of human
diseases
we quite simply need better viruses so
in other words gene therapy is starting
to work but many diseases are still
beyond the capabilities
of current delivery technologies and we
need new aavs
so what are the some of the existing
challenges with aavs
the first one i've indirectly alluded to
already which is the fact that ninety
percent of us have
are exposed to one or more aav variants
and as a result we've been you know
accidentally vaccinated against the
virus and high concentrations of
antibodies that will neutralize
natural versions of aib and so that's a
significant barrier within the field
it's
in fact the most common reason that
patients are turned away from clinical
trials
in addition after the virus potentially
makes it past those antibodies
it inefficiently distributes to most
target tissues inside the body
it tends to go very well to the liver
but not as well to many other tissues
there's inefficient spread in those
tissues um
once the virus is able to reach the
surface it can't penetrate deep inside
of that tissue
if it reaches uh near the target cells
it has
the ability right now to target delivery
to some cell types but not others within
that tissue
and even if it reaches the surface of an
intended target cell
it's often taken up very poorly by that
cell so these are after all respiratory
viruses and it's a lot to ask of them
to be able to very efficiently infect
other target cell types such as a neuron
or a
cardiomyocyte so all these shortcomings
arose from a very simple fact which is
that nature never evolved viruses for
our convenience to use as medicines
and so around 20 years ago we developed
a hypothesis that
if we'd like to improve the properties
of these viruses for therapy
we need to re-evolve them or re-engineer
them at the molecular level
so the toolkit or the methodology that
was emerging in the field that we saw a
promise and enabling us to do this
was the product of an investigator by
the name of francis arnold
she actually see berkeley back in the
80s and since the time she's been a
professor at caltech
and she won the nobel prize in chemistry
in 2018 for the concept of using
evolution as a tool
to design novel function into
biomolecules so she did this
specifically with industrial enzymes
and we became the first to do it with
viruses like aav
so this approach about directed
evolution and i'll explain how it works
in just a second
we've been conducting it the past 20
years with aav and we've have
multiple examples in which we've used
this approach to be able to create new
aavs
that have overcome some of these
barriers i talked to you about
before with a variety of cell and tissue
targets
so the way that this technology works is
uh it's based upon evolution
and evolution has two basic steps uh the
first is to create a gene pool and the
second is to select the fittest
so as a gene pool we take several
natural versions of this virus
and we perform a number of steps to
genetically diversify them
and uh specifically i'm not going to go
into this in great detail
but we've created some libraries in
which we've generated chimeras of
several of these parent viruses and
generated new variants that contain
pieces of individual parents
we've uh used bioinformatics and
computational approaches to reconstruct
family trees of avs and began to predict
sequences of these viruses that may have
existed
a long time ago and built libraries
around those a process known as
ancestral reconstruction
and in fact we have those two libraries
and 35 others that we've utilized to
introduce diversity into that viral code
protein in a variety of different ways
so that's the gene pool where we then
package these into libraries of
particles where every single variant
or every single particle is composed of
a varying protein shell a variant capsid
contains inside of it the dna that
encodes that capsid
so we'll then as the second step play
darwin select the fittest and i'll
describe to you some selections
and by spinning around this loop
iteratively we can end up
evolving or selective variants and have
desirable properties and at any point
along the way
pop open the particles and sequence the
genomes to recover the
informationally the sequences or
composition of those capsids
uh that mediated the efficient gene
delivery or the efficient targeting to a
given
a specific tissue and once we have those
new engineered capsids we can then begin
to utilize them to deliver dna medicines
so just to outline today i'm going to
show you a couple of topics that we've
been working on
one is engineering aavs for the retina
to be able to treat blinding conditions
another is for the central nervous
system and then i'm going to switch
gears a little bit afterwards and
talking about our efforts towards using
this approach to be able to solve
problems
in process engineering for aavs
so as i mentioned to you the very first
fda approved gene therapy for a rare
disease
involved in aav for treatment in the
retina and this is the structure of your
eye
at the back of the eye you have a number
of layers of neurons that are painted
onto that surface area
and all the way at the back the
so-called onl or outer nuclear layer
and this contains the photoreceptor
neurons cells that sense photons
so once uh a photon hits one of those
cells it fires an action potential and
it communicates that information
to various interneurons in the inl inner
nuclear layer
gcl the ganglion cell layer and
these gcl neurons will then uh send
information along their axons through
that uh white line that lies at the
or sorry yellow line at the back of the
eye which is the optic nerve
and the eye then communicates that infra
information to the brain for further
processing
so the place you would like to be able
to uh one final point i'd like to make
is that in the back of the eye in the
center there's a region called the fovea
that contains a high concentration of
cone photoreceptors
and this is what's responsible for high
visual acuity so if you're reading a
page and your eye scans back and forth
what your eye is doing is keeping the
light from a page focused in on the
phobia
because you need that high acuity vision
in order to read the page
so this is an important region of the
retinas to protect so
unfortunately mutations in over 200
different genes
can result in the death of photoreceptor
neurons in the eye
and other conditions such as macular
degeneration
can also kill off the cell layer many
many patients um
age-related macular degeneration affects
over one to two million patients within
the united states
so the place you would like to deliver a
drug to be able to treat these
conditions
is through into the vitreous the eye
this fluid or gel like substance in the
inside of the eye because if you can do
an injection there it's very simple it
takes around four seconds
local anesthesia only and this gives
your drug the opportunity to be able to
diffuse throughout the eye and to come
into contact with the full surface area
of the retina and therefore protect the
majority of cells inside the rep
and in fact this intervitual injection
is conducted several million times a
year in the united states
to deliver protein drugs produced by
genentech and regeneron
to be able to treat age-related macular
degeneration
so unfortunately the
the cells of the inl and the gcl
represent a barrier where you would like
your aav to deliver the dna medicine to
the photoreceptor neurons that's the
target for the therapy
but unfortunately no natural version of
aav can actually distribute or transport
through the several hundred microns of
dense tissue
it would take to be able to make the
trip from the vitreous fluid all the way
back to the outer nuclear layer
so as a result natural versions of aav
have to be injected right next to that
target cell
so in that fda approved product for
example which uses aav2
natural serotype 2 for aav they have had
to take the needle
actually puncture it through the retina
and inject fluid between the outer
nuclear layer
and the underlying retinal pigment
epithelium and
uh this is is problematic for a couple
of reasons
so first of all it detaches the retina
and at the injection site
uh this retinal detachment can actually
cause some damage
and second the uh the injection of the
fluid behind the photoreceptors
um results in the spread only in a small
bubble or bleb
where the fluid ends up causing that
retinal detachment so this mediates
delivery of aav to those target cells
and only around
five to ten percent of the surface area
of the retina so in that fda approved
product they're actually sacrificing
around ninety percent of the cells the
progression the disease
so we asked the question can we do this
can we actually evolve aavs to be able
to reach this target cell deep inside a
tissue
which is representative of many problems
in gene therapy where you would like the
virus to spread throughout a tissue to
be able to reach inaccessible cells
so the way that we did this is that
there was no
cell culture model that was capable of
recapitulating the complex structure of
the retina for a long enough period of
time for us to conduct the evolution
so we we did this in vivo we took our
library of viral particles
and in sum total at that stage our
library size was around 100 million
different aav variants
we then administered these initially in
a proof of concept study
into a mouse retina waited a certain
amount of time for the winners to be
able to traffic back to the
photoreceptors shown in the bottom in
green
using fluorescence activated cell
sorting recovered the aav
genomes that made it to those cells
because those particles carried the dna
then encoded the viral particle along
for the ride you could think of them as
being barcoded with their own dna
and uh then repackaged the library
readministered it
went through six rounds of selection so
that that initially very rich pool ended
up converging
just down to a small handful of aav
variants shown there on the bottom left
hand corner
with one particularly dominant variant
which comprised around three quarters of
the pool
that particular variant which we called
seven m8
has a has a structural cartoon showed on
the bottom right hand side
where we see in green there were some
changes in the amino acid composition on
the viral surface
specifically a peptide was inserted into
that region of a very specific sequence
and you can also see some dots in red so
we had some point mutations as well
within that variant we wanted to test
the ability of that variant to start
carrying recombinant dna inside of cells
so we initially loaded it with dna
encoding the green fluorescent protein
and began to test its delivery
properties in the mouse eye
compared to a parent virus specifically
aav
serotype ii so shown there on the bottom
left is aav2
the vitreous fluid is on the bottom side
the photoreceptors are on the
see why in that fda for approved product
they have to use a needle and a
subrental injection to place the av
right next to the photoreceptors because
aav2 from the vitreous
can't even reach the photoreceptors so
this compares to the the variant that we
created 7m8
where you can see that uh we're carrying
gfp we're comparing the dna to every
single
roughly cell population all the way from
the bottom the retinal ganglion cells to
the top
the retinal pigment epithelium and
furthermore we're doing this
across much larger surface area than
five to ten percent of the retina we're
actually
delivering dna to the full surface area
of the retina
so this was an initial proof of concept
study within
mouse and we wanted to test how well it
translated to
to larger animals and we didn't
necessarily anticipate it would
translate well to for example to a
primate
simply because evolution teaches you you
get what you select for
we selected and erode it we got a really
good rodent vector
and the structure of the road and eye is
quite simply different from that of
larger mammals
in a couple of ways shown here is size
that as you move from a mouse to a dog
to a a monkey a cinemalogous macaque
uh to a human eye there's an increase in
the size of the retina where a mouse has
on the order of a
100 microliters of vitreous fluid
whereas a human has 4 000
microliters of vitreous fluid and
macaque is closer to 3 000
and there's some structural differences
as well i'm just wanted to remind you
that this phobia is the region
of the back of the human eye that is
responsible for high acuity vision
it's a particularly important region to
protect mice don't even have a phobia
so you can't study the effects of a gene
therapy on protecting the phobia
very well within a mouse in addition
there's a
matrix barrier extracellular matrix
barrier that lies between the fluid of
the eye
and the the retina the neural retina and
that's called the air interlimiting
membrane
and it's been shown in a number of
studies by ourselves and others that
this poses a significant barrier to gene
delivery
and that ilm that layer is quite simply
thicker within larger eyes such as
monkey and human so we wanted to test
what
how this mouse variant did uh within
within macaques within
animals monkeys rather and so we tested
using a number of natural versions of
aav
89 2 5 and 8. and what we see is this
this transduction pattern um
on the lower right hand side you can see
the region the reason for it
that the inner limiting membrane is
pretty thick across the majority of the
surface area of the retina
it thins out right around the phobia and
in that region it begins to expose some
of those superficial neurons those
retinal ganglion cells that uh kind of
encircle or surround the phobia region
and so you end up with a ring of
transduction around the phobia a ring of
retinal ganglion cells
but on the bottom of the bottom right
hand side you can see those cones those
important cells you'd like to protect
and if this variant were these variants
were delivering dna to those cells you
would see
white in the interior of that circle but
you can see there is none
because those natural versions of av
aren't reaching those cells
so this is the variant 7m8 that we
created we can see there's better
transduction
across a number of puncta across the
retina
and those turned out to be regions where
the vasculature
within the retina actually resulted in
the thinning of that inner limiting
membrane
and in addition we can see in the middle
of the eye that phobia we do have
some transduction some delivery to cone
photoreceptors
so it's better than the natural versions
but we felt we could do even better
we're not getting broad widespread
uniform transduction across the retina
so uh however this this variant was uh
was deemed enough able to treat a
particular condition
age-related macular degeneration and a
company
down in in menlo park uh known as an
avira i
just i wanted to mention that i had no
affiliation with this company
but they licensed uh this variant 7m8
from uc berkeley
and took it into a human clinical trial
back in november 2018
to carry uh dna encoding and
anti-vascular endothelial growth factor
inhibitor to be able to treat patients
with wet
age-related macular degeneration and uh
they've reported uh more recently as
recently as january now that uh the
first cohort of six patients who were
dosed back uh
starting in november 2018 have now
for a period of uh approaching a year
and a half
been off the protein therapy that i
mentioned to you earlier there are
anti-veg f protein therapies that are
injected into the eye of the order of 10
times a year
drugs that were manufactured or produced
by by genentech and regeneron
so these patients have been off of those
monthly injections of the protein
therapy for almost a year and a half now
and they their vision is stable and the
structure of the retina appears to be
stabilized as well
uh and this is just showing that that
press release specifically calls out uh
that variant 7ma
however we felt that we could do better
for the the gene expression pattern we
could get more widespread transduction
across
area the retina so we began to move
towards larger models
of the retina ones that bore
significantly higher resemblance
to the human eye and to do so we started
with a dog
so i mentioned to you that fda approved
product for a blinding condition
libras can judge the lamarosis type 2.
and this
earlier i mentioned that that particular
gene therapy and it turns out the dog
played a major role in the clinical
development or the pre-clinical
development of this therapy
specifically because there is a natural
strain of dog
which has a mutation in that same gene
called rp
rpe65 whose mutation causes that disease
within human beings
so as a pre-clinical step an
investigator at the university of
pennsylvania gene bennett
treated these dogs and showed that she
could get correction of vision within
these animals uh prior to moving on to
human beings and showing therapeutic
efficacy within humans
so in collaboration with william beltran
also at the university of pennsylvania
we began to conduct directed evolution
within the dog retina
and uh so we repeated the directed
evolution
except within dog and uh after a number
of rounds of evolution
we uh we began to isolate some variants
of aav
so one difference between our initially
doing this within mouse and more
recently within dog
is that sequencing technology has gotten
a lot better and specifically we
began to use illumina sequencing to
characterize convergence of our library
over time
and you can see here a through f these
are a number of different libraries
within our pool
um and specifically these are libraries
in which we made changes to a specific
small stretch
of the surface of the capsid for example
by inserting a random peptide sequence
into those regions
and on the y-axis you can see the number
of independent variants
which ranges typically from a million to
10 million variants for each one of
those libraries
and you can see on the x-axis
progressive steps in the evolution
process where the first line is plasmid
that's the original library as we cloned
it
av library means we've packaged it once
and packaging
into recombinant virus plays or exerts a
selective pressure
where not all of the the changes that we
made into the capsule
are going to result in capsids that can
stabilize fold so we
see a selection there for package
ability if you will
and then rounds one through six were
progressive rounds of selection for the
ability of those
variants to reach target cells inside
the eye
we observed something interesting in the
original library to begin with
this is the plasmid library and
ordinarily you would ideally like to see
that every single recombinant variant
had an equal shot on goal had an equal
opportunity to be able to show off to be
able to reach the retina
but some of these had actually stacked
the deck and on the left hand side you
can see that
there are some that where there's a
significantly higher abundance
relative to the majority of variants um
which
are equally represented as indicated by
by
the fact that most of those curves have
a flat line towards the right-hand side
but on the left-hand side you can see
some variants uh due to we believe
artifact associated with the
oligonucleotide dna synthesis
from dna synthesis companies where we
ordered um random sequences from those
companies
there was some bias that led some
variants to be represented
as much as a hundred or a thousand times
higher in frequency relative to the rest
of the members in the library
so to be able to make sure those
variants didn't have an unfair advantage
we conducted evolution in which we
sequence the distribution of variance
emerging from from the darwinian
selection every single round along the
way
and this is the selection and
we're going to run through this regard
sorry
where on the y-axis we have the
percentage
of each one of those variants each
variant within the pool is represented
as a single dot in that dot plot
where the y-axis shows what percentage
of the pool
those dots comprised after you know it
was packaged in that first plot after
round one two three
three four five six axis um that is
compared to the percentage of the
frequency of that variant within the
original plasmid library
so what you'd like to see is that some
variants should you know of course stay
in the same position on the x-axis
because they had a particular presence a
particular percentage
or frequency within the original library
but you'd like to see some
rise up progressively higher and higher
on the the y-axis
indicating that they're being selected
for they're increasing in frequency as a
result of the evolution process
furthermore the ones that um had an
unfair advantage
to begin with are shown there in green
and uh the ones that
um ultimately are the winners after
round six you can see in the lower right
hand side
um shown in red those are the most
frequent variants within round six you
can see where they lay within the
original rounds uh there were low
frequency variants but progressively
climbed the y-axis over time
and so the ones we really focused on
were the ones that were red but not
blue not the ones that were the most
abundant
within the original pool and those were
the variants that we wanted to then test
so the way that we tested them is that
each animal subject is quite precious
both for ethics as well as economical
reasons so we took a number of different
variants on the order of 20
and we used each one of those capsids to
package
a a particular genome that contained the
green fluorescent protein and also
contained inside of it
a small barcode a molecular identifier
where
the identity of that barcode shown in
the upper left-hand corner there that
plot
um there was a one-to-one correlation or
relationship between the sequence of
that barcode and which of those variants
shown at the bottom right hand corner
um in that circle which one of those red
variants was used to
barcode so we packaged 20 different
barcodes with 20 different capsids
individually
and then pooled all of them together
administered
mixed them together injected them into
the retina
of a dog and then both visualized the
retina so you can see here
that we have a large number of cells
that are expressing the green
fluorescent protein
which means that at least one or more of
those variants
of aav the new genera the new variants
that we created
were capable of carrying their dna deep
inside of the retina
however we can then isolate the
photoreceptor neurons
and use dna sequencing to recover the
frequency of those barcodes
within that tissue and that tells us
which capsules were capable of carrying
dna very efficiently inside of that
tissue and which variants were capable
as a result
of mediating the expression of high
levels of gfp high levels of messenger
rna
within those cells so
we took our entire pool we applied it
into the mouse just as a control and
then we applied it within the dog
and we can see a number of interesting
features here uh shown on the right hand
side you can see that regardless of
whether we apply it to master dog aav2
is near the bottom
indicating that that natural version of
av is not very effective
um on the right hand two columns we can
see that uh the variants that we call
canine
canine number nine and number sixteen
were very effective at uh being able to
mediate uh delivery in gene expressing
the dog
but if you take a look within the mouse
uh canine
nine and sixteen are a little bit lower
this tells us that there's sequence
specificity
for which variant optimal again telling
you that nature
teaches us to get what you select for in
an evolution
so if you want to do that if you want to
create variants that are optimal within
a larger animal model that tells you you
can't do the selection within the mouse
you have to do it within the larger
animal
and you see the converse as well that
the top variant within the mouse k912 is
actually lower on the list
within the dock so we took the top
variant
k916 and we then
tested it individually within the eye
and we actually
generated two genomes just to test its
ability to mediate delivery both within
photoreceptor neurons
as well as the other target cell within
the eye that i haven't talked about too
much yet which is the retinal pigment
epithelium
so we specifically loaded uh two
different genomes into that variant
one that contains gfp under the control
of a photoreceptor promoter
and the other one which contains uh td
tomato or red fluorescent protein under
the control of rat they'll pick me up at
the alien promoter
uh we compared this to the variant
within the literature that had been
reported to be the best for delivery to
the dog eye from the vitreous
a variant called av24y
plus tv and you can see our variant here
the k916
at various levels of magnification is
mediating
very very high transduction very high
levels of delivery and gene expression
both within photoceptors shown in green
as well as with retinal pigment
epithelium shown in red
so ultimately we of course were
were very interested in translating this
into the clinic into human gene therapy
to be able to treat the 200 plus
blinding diseases
that rob people love their vision so i'm
going to show you a couple of slides now
in which we uh conducted the evolution
within non-human primate within
cinemalgous macaque
and this was work that was done at a
company that i co-founded
uh called 4d molecular therapeutics it's
now an 83-person
uh company located in emeryville
california
that is uh taking these these products
into human clinical trials
so this the y-axis uh sequencing results
or the percentage of the pool
of variants that were recovered after
every single round or at least rounds
three through six
um the pool that came from
photoreceptors from the inner nuclear
layer and from the retinal ganglion cell
layer as well as the
pigment epithelium layer and there was
one particular variant where you can see
that regardless of which one of these
layers you're looking at it was the
dominant variant
comprising in some cases over 80 percent
of the variants that were
emerging from that from that region
uh we then took this variant use it to
package the green fluorescent protein
and began to conduct uh studies that
were
ind enabling and shown here is a
fluorescence live
fundus image of uh in this case several
non-human primates
um and you can see that uh there's a
widespread expression at the back of
their eyes this is actually six months
after delivery of that aav carrying the
green fluorescent protein into these
animal eyes
and we took these animals post life and
did
literally thousands of histological
sections and
you can see that some regions are
brighter than others
but across the entire retina even in
whether it's the regions that are white
or gray
in the upper left-hand corner we see a
high level of expression of the green
fluorescent protein
across multiple layers within the retina
so based on this we've actually filed
two inds to the fda these are now open
inds where we have authorization to
initiate human
gene therapy clinical trials uh for
x-linked retinitis pigmentosa
as well as for chorioremia uh when
things calm down around the world
we're going to be initiating those human
clinical trials
um in addition our company 4d molecular
therapeutics has
extended this evolution approach where
our pool of variance now is a billion
so 37 different libraries a billion
different aavs
and we've done selections not just in
the retina but in the central nervous
system lung liver heart etc
so actually 14 selections to date that
have resulted in 300 novel variants of
aav
that we've created and the the next
target tissue that we're going to be
clinically pursuing is actually muscle
uh both skeletal and heart muscle and
we're soon going to be
this month filing an ind to be able to
initiate clinical trials to treat fat
rays
so i'd like to to talk about a different
mode of delivery
um for gene delivery in the central
nervous system and it's actually a
different mechanism of spread
of virus into this tissue a process
called retrograde transport
so whether the tissue is the eye or the
brain or the heart
we have some some fundamental problems
which is that these are relatively large
tissues
and can be very delicate surgically and
it's difficult to get aav to spread
to a large amount of that tissue so uh
one of the
the clinical trials that illustrated
within the brain uh this concept or this
problem is uh was to treat this
lysosomal storage disease called
saint palepo b and to be able to try to
infuse aav through a majority of the
volume of the brain they actually
drilled eight holes into the skull and
did 16 aav injections
and still didn't restore high enough
levels of enzymes to be able to modify
the disease in that condition
we co-discovered a mechanism for av
transport within the brain called
retrograde transport
so specifically we know neurons have a
cell body where the nucleus is
and then they extend for the extent
axons in some cases uh millimeters or
many centimeters inside the body
and we found that if you deposit an aav
right at the end of one of these axons
um the the axon can actually internalize
the virus and traffic it back
retrogradely along that axon for very
long distances in some
cases infect
remotely if you will and this was
utilized subsequently by brian kaspar in
a study back in 2003
in which he injected aav into the muscle
of a mouse
and the virus was internalized by the
axons of motor neurons
and the motor neurons then retrogradely
trafficked the aav back to the spinal
cord
and this is a way of being able to
mediate high efficiency or relatively
high efficiency delivery to the spinal
cord of that mouse
after a simple intramuscular injection
leaking the virus brain barrier and use
this to
to mediate a protective factor into the
uh central nervous system a mouse model
of amitropic lateral sclerosis and this
extended animal life ban
so a company began to develop this
retrograde transport technology and
unfortunately found out that the
efficiency of retrograde transport
was too low it worked reasonably well
within a mouse less well within a rat
and not well at all within a non-human
primate and so it became
too easy to scale up for human clinical
use even though this could be a
very effective approach to be able to
get spread within the central nervous
system
as i'll show you in a couple of examples
so we began to to conduct uh av
evolution for retrograde transport and
the system that we utilized is uh shown
right here
um this was initially done within a
mouse and the
the cortex of these animals uh sends
projections
over a long distance to a centralized
region called the ponds
so the idea is that you could do an
injection of the library inside
the pons and some cortical neurons would
would end up internalizing that virus
and retrogradely transporting it back to
the cortex
and as a result with a single focal
injection you could get the virus to
spread through a large volume within the
cortex
of the brain so we repeated this
evolution multiple times
and ended up with one dominant variant
emerging we then loaded it
with the transgene that would end up
resulting in expression of a td tomato
and you can see a single injection into
the ponds result in a very widespread
expression across the brain
so we wanted to to quantify the level of
uh
increase in this retrograde transport so
we ended up
loading several different aavs
with the cargo that resulted in
expression of gfp just within the
nucleus
this is td tomato across the cytosol of
cells so it's kind of hard to count
individual neurons
this was a nuclearly localized cargo so
we can see that
upon injection into the pawns in the
lower left hand side
you should get expression across the
cortex in the upper right hand side
there's none
in the case of ab2 in the case of this
particular variant called a
dj this this came out of stanford you
can see at least in the bottom panel
that there's some neurons um
in the upper right hand side and the
cortex expressing gfp
but it's not comparable it's this
variant the av2 retro that we created
we can see widespread transduction
across those neurons
when we quantify the efficiency of
delivery you can see that
compared to av-1 to 8-9 we have
a 50-100 fold higher levels of
retrograde transport
and it compares quite well to a number
of other approaches for retrograde
transport
including even this fluorescent dye in
an organic molecule called fluoro gold
which has been utilized for
retrograde transport labeling
we then wanted to see strategically with
a couple of different injections how we
could maximize spread across the brain
and you can see here if we do three
different injections with three
different aavs of three different colors
um red green and blue into the superior
colliculus
thalamus and ponds respectively um just
these three focal injections gets you
wider spread expression across
large volumes inside the brain and we've
since utilized this to
affect genome editing within the brain
as described in that article in the
bottom right hand side
so i'd like to to move on quickly to the
the chapter the work i wanted to
describe to you today which is
um going to be some work that carries on
the same concept of solving problems
through libraries and evolution
but now applies it towards a different
problem which is av production
so there's been as gene therapy has been
increasingly successful
there's been a a bottleneck within the
field related to av manufacturing as
shown here in this relatively old
article from the uh the new york times
and this problem is illustrated here uh
so
av serotype nine which is the serotype
that's used for that
fda approved product to be able to treat
spinal muscular atrophy
so from around a 500 meter square
bioreactor you can create on the order
of 10 to the 16th viral particles
so you can then translate in this into
how much surface area you need to be
able to treat individual patients
who are suffering from certain
conditions so in the bot in the middle
here we have one sma patient
and they typically treat uh this is
novartis um avexis
they treat uh patients um typically on
the order of weeks of life so they're
treating young young patients just
post-natally and as a result you don't
need as much virus because simply
you know young patients aren't as big
yet so even so you need around 50 square
meters to do a patient
and av9 is also in clinical trials to be
able to treat duchene muscular dystrophy
and in that case you need 500 meters
squared and otherwise in other words
in some cases a single manufacturing run
per dmd patient treated
so how does this translate to the
incident and prevalent populations
you need around 20 000 meters square to
treat the annual incidence of a spinal
muscular atrophy type one
and you need around seven and a half
million square meters to be able to
treat the prevalent uh
duchenne muscular dystrophy population
so this is is actually hundreds of
around the order of a thousand
uh soccer ball fields uh worth of
surface area
so they're quite simply it's going to be
challenging to have enough manufacturing
capacity to to treat
these conditions so one way in which you
can ease the manufacturing burden is by
creating an aav that's much more
targeted and efficient at being able to
reach a tissue
so let's say you created a directed
evolution aav that's 100 fold better
getting there well that's going to
alleviate the manufacturing burden
but another way in which you could do it
is to actually engineer the
manufacturing cells to pump out more av
and we begin
to do that using a based upon
investigators within the field of n wide
expression perturbations where um in
some cases they're actually using a
version of cas9 fused to uh
transcriptional activator system and
then as a result
guide rnas will guide this
transcriptional activator this
effectively a synthetic transcription
factor to
you know depending upon the guide many
different locations of the genome and so
you can develop genome-wide activation
libraries or you could use a cas9
that has an active nuclease and got
using a guide rna
target that cas9 towards let's say the
first exon of every gene within the
human genome
and generate genome-wide knockout
libraries and so these
guide rna libraries are what direct
these different
systems either a transcriptional
activator or a knockout system
towards particular regions within the
genome
so we ended up embedding these guide
libraries
into aav vectors so that we could select
for
guides or specifically for genes whose
over expression or whose knockout
could increase aav production and we did
this within 293 cells
which is the dominant manufacture cell
line to produce produce aavs
so the rationale for this was that just
like we'd anticipate that
nature is never evolutionarily rewarded
in an aav
capsid for the reach of photoreceptor
neuron inside deep inside the eye
you know just it's not part of the aav
life cycle um
likely nature has never evolutionarily
rewarded a 293 cell which is a
a transformed cell line that was derived
from embryonic kidney
human embryonic kidney is never
evolutionarily rewarded for
for the ability to pump out aav so the
opportunity to engineer
the cell line to be able to better do
that
so the way that we did this is that we
created libraries of guide rnas inside
of av where we cloned in
all seventy thousand guides present
within this initial system
which contains uh the seventy thousand
contains three guides per gene
for each of uh 23 000 genes within the
human genome
or the gecko the knockout library
contains three guides for each of
nineteen thousand genes so
fifty eight thousand guide library so we
cloned those inside of aav
and packaged it along with the wrap cap
helper and an adenoviral helper
so that we created libraries of aav
vectors where every single variant on
the right hand side
can has the same capsule gene in this
case but contains a different guide rna
inside of it
we can then take these and infect it
infect cells with them at a low ratio of
virus to cell so each cell took up
only one virus and as a result expresses
only one guide rna
and these cells now have the crispr cast
system
which can take the guides and either
over express or
knock out a particular gene uh depending
upon the nature of the av library
so we then gave this the cell around 48
hours to perturb gene expression through
that over expression or that knockout
and uh then uh transfected in the
helpers
so that we could then use that cell to
manufacture aav
and the logic is that if a particular
over expression
of a given gene in the human genome or a
knockout of a given gene in the human
genome
ended up changing the cell in such a way
that it could better produce
aav then that cell is going to pump out
more aav
and just to remind you that aav genome
is
getting inside of it the barcode the
information that tells us
which gene perturbation resulted in the
better production of aav
so we can then harvest that library use
it to reinfect the cells
repackage and as time goes on the av
variants that or the guide rnas if you
will inside those aavs that results in
better packaging
are going to get exponentially amplified
within the population
and at the end we can then do um
sequencing
uh next-gen illumina sequencing to
sequence the guides and tell us
which genes uh whose perturbation would
result in an
increase in aav production so we have a
number of different hits
and two particularly interesting hits
emerged from the over expression library
uh one is called itp rip which is an
asymptote triphosphate receptor
interacting protein
so this modulates calcium release inside
of cells in response to
signals that release that result in itp
production
and scotu spindle and kinetochore
associated protein type 2 which is
involved so we took
cells 293 cells and over expressed these
two proteins
initially by over expressing the guide
and cas9 system
and then we did it dna encoding these
proteins and over expressing them inside
of cells
and we found out that upon over
expression of these proteins we get
around
a two to three fold increase behavior
production from these cells
and uh this is both at the level of
vector genomes produced
as well as infectious units produced and
furthermore
there was the possibility that these two
genes could be acting independently
within those cells and therefore by
combining them we can get synergistic
increases
and we see that upon over expressing
both cells we get around a four to five
fold increase
in in vector production and furthermore
this was not limited to aav2 but
extended to
other av stereotypes such as ab6 which
is notorious for being a particularly
difficult beat to produce and we see a
two to four around a three to four
increase in both viral tighter
genome tighter as well as infectious
unit titer
so we have since this investigating
mechanisms by which over-expression of
these genes
ends up resulting in better aav
production and we're seeing evidence
that these genes actually
perturb cell cycle in a way that is
advantageous for aav
production and we look forward to going
into detail into that mechanism soon
but i'd like to close now with a few
bullet points from the work that i have
presented the first is that gene therapy
is working
in addition recombinant safe viruses
like aav can be can represent very
potent therapeutic pharmaceutical gene
delivery vehicles
but of course nature didn't optimize
them for uses as use
in human therapies and therefore it's up
to re up to us to re-optimize these
viruses
to be safe effective efficient uh
therapies
so these particles are very complex
products of millions of years of
evolution and it's very difficult to
rationally engineer
changes into them however directed
evolution ends up being a very powerful
search algorithm
where we can search billions of
potential viral sequences to be able to
isolate the variants that have highly
optimized properties
for delivery in principle to any cell or
tissue target through
an optimal route of administration and
we use this approach to create avs that
have a highly
um that are highly efficient can target
delivery or in work that i didn't talk
about today
can also get past that pre-existing
antibody problem within the human
population
so one of the av very we've created has
already been in the clinic for almost a
year and a half and
uh several additional variants are going
to be entering into the clinic this year
so i'd like to acknowledge the people
who actually did the work uh the work
within the retina
was the product uh this is mouse retina
the product of leah burn denise dalcara
and tim day
in collaboration with john flannery at
uc berkeley uh the work
in the dog retina uh was the product of
of
again leah byrne at uc berkeley and john
flannery
in collaboration with welling beltran
university of pennsylvania
the work in the non-human primate retina
uh came out of
4d molecular therapeutics and i
especially like to call out david curran
my co-founder
and her ceo and
the work on retrograde transport was a
product of tom guy and bombio wong on
collaboration with investigators
at genealia farms and uh finally uh the
work
on the uh development of better av
manufacturing cell lines uh was the
product of chris barnes and david ojala
so thank you so much and uh thank you
for your time
and listening to our work